bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono fa vj cosa tocchi cosa tocchi
oggi siamo su agoni ecco la normale
normale siamo sua coni che un gioco
horror molto figo
credo che ha intelligenza calcoli numero
della bestia essa rappresenta il numero
duomo 666 vuol dire che sono
intelligente segnatevelo perché l'ha
detto gioco sono partito va bene
si è partiti ragazzi che bello salve
sono arrivato adesso all'inferno perché
per che monetizza voi video su youtube
che succede è sparito
perché ti ho detto che faccio youtuber
non ti piaceva al cosa se va bene o che
schifo ma che piedi ciò vela ma a doha
cos'è sta roba qua premi e per
interagire con gli oggetti quest'ora
intuitivo posso prendere la torcia molto
bene quindi ragazzi stiamo facendo un
viaggio all'inferno questo quando si
finisce all'inferno in teoria si vive
questa cosa che state vedendo bene ma
sei scemo a ok dovevo darfo castano
chiaro ho preso la torcia è buttata dopo
un secondo poso la porta si apre bella
lì
da quell'altra cosa che non riesca a
satana permesso quindi questo mi formi
dovrebbe portare al traguardo di qua
beh certo fai un'offerta all'altare ok 5
euro vanno bene c'è qualcosa o forse
questo qua posso donarti chidono un per
un cuore ti dono al mio cuore tieni
siamo adesso la bilancia è quasi
bilanciata ma non l'effetto devo trovare
permette un altro cuore che sparso in
giro qualcuno ha un cuore me lo presti
un cuore per cortesia non fosse
un'apertura se avete un cuore mi cada
prestarmi permesso o quante mani a c'è
un tizio salve poverino nuovo visse
cuore no mi sa che non me lo pressano ok
no mi serve il cui il cuore le braccia
non me ne faccio niente anche del piede
va bene a me basta che all'inferno non
ci siano i ragni poi sono contento
eccolo avendo davanti solo per capire
chi è che sta piangendo con salve
cosa è successo qua
[Musica]
vado a fuoco a caso ma mi sono
pronunciato da solo
deficiente va bene ho un cuore quindi
torniamo indietro se si può tornare
indietro alla pittura ma io come ci
passo di quando scusa
[Musica]
ok sentivo qualcuno piangere prima mica
piangi per me devi e ci mancherebbe
notizia peso salve e bellissimo lei
l'ultima frase la dici a tua sorella è
grazie a lei bellaria e vai dargli fuoco
ecco perfetto perché sono così
divertente affettato il fuoco sto tipo
siamo tornati da van prima dovevo
mettere il salone del giudizio posso
mettere il cuore qui comunque i miei
piedi fanno veramente schifo e non
vorrei dire a posto quindi ora posso
andare avanti non ho più la torcia
avrebbe dato fuoco al tipo per permesso
sempre che è la voce di la gnocca però
non fa cosa mi dice che non sarà così
allora ecco qui vado avanti un culo
c'era un culo era l'unica cosa bella
avevo visto finora perché va via
hai appena trovato il frutto della
sapienza hanno trovato un culo però non
è andato giù o sa ma tu sei quello di
prima non ha capito trovare un simbolo
come quello o c'è la b per vendemmia
però non è il simbolo giusto trova il
modo di uscire alla b ricco da labirinto
menta posso farlo io mamma mia che
brutto braccio che devo disegnare un
culo
va bene tua madre non mi accetti niente
cosa vuoi dalla mia vita ma scusa dalle
fila di aromi che devo fare un attimino
a cagare ma guarda 12 ore per passava
attiva i punti di controllo raccoglie il
è stato della dea per ottenere
stracciati piatti ok quest'anno sarà
questo un teschio teschio pregio va bene
se l'ho visto
c'è un demone con le bocce che è sceso
quindi mi sa che uscirà nel ca pranzi
non scappare
statte zitto che c'è gente qua madonna
gioco e benzina c'è un pene lì il frico
arico di confetture successo mi sono
dovuto dai veloce quanto tempo vai vai
vai vai vai vai vai che già un casino
quanta ansia per giocare questa roba non
la vedeva va bene posso passare a cui
non c'era traporti milin chiedo da fisco
a tutti siamo all'inferno come faceva
aver difficoltà da fuoco alle cose c'è
una torcia l'inverso prendiamoci aprile
la bellissima mamma perché vi do fuoco
da solo ogni volta di mortacci nia va a
jesus quanto difficile è perfetto basta
basta è gente de ma
tua madre morta che ansia cos'era ma va
a cagare va per un tipo nel muro che
ansia un labirinto questo pieno di roba
c'è una tipa gigante è sta roba qua un
mio dio la sua carciofi prendi prendi
prevista roba teschio preso le morti di
qua per fece un buco amen
meno male almeno dovrebbero arrivarci
spero perché mi tempo era ingestibile
adesso ma poi ci sono i bambini che
hanno delle candele sopra la testa cioè
sta cosa non l'ho capita ma no ma non è
vero sono trovate all'inizio tutto sto
casino sono tornati qua allora andiamo
dall'altra parte a sto punto ho fatto un
giro strano e non è servito a niente
salve coppe ti sei sperduto completa
rituale significa chi fugge da questo
labirinto della mente che schifo frana
23 il 3 non ce l'ho porca vacca neanche
a 1 e sono stato bravo conquista di qua
la cosa vedo vedo cose senta mi
servirebbe un teschio sono vado più
avanti un casino ci sarà passato che con
la fusione gullo storia era quel posto
lì perfetto perfetto perfetto così mi
piace non gioco bene maledizione mi
piace
bravo così apre di sedano via che è
bello e sei un gioco simpatico verona
cioè se ci sono poi c'è un po ovunque
però vabbè
non so cosa sia veloce ci possono salire
guardando indietro come è possibile
vabbè al suo cammino di tipo matrix cioè
non avevo capito va bene
mamma mia che brutta roba sono arrivato
dall altra parte
considerando che mi ero buttato da lì
davanti basta bocce bocci abbastanza per
tutti è accaduto nel ciclo alcuni
dipinti possono occultare le verità tua
insaputa
va bene mentre nel dipinto davanti a
salve e professore lancerà metti la
fossa raggiunge il fondo della forza
fatto
apple chi commette il peccato viene dal
diavolo perché il diavolo e peccatore
fin dal principio
anche chi non mette rai che i miei video
stessa cosa quindi veloci adesso quindi
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto è stato inebriante giocare a
sta roba veramente però di bocce
generano quell ora vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come se ci sono da me mi piace
ha chiarito che mi dà notizia rete e non
ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]